en un anónimo almacén dejar que estos
jóvenes descargan cajas de comida y
medicinas son parte de la resistencia o
craneana redes que trabajan a la sombra
para atender a los civiles el estado se
ocupa de la guerra ellos de la población
la devastación del conflicto ha activado
estas células de ciudadanos como la de
yan un joven recién licenciado en
literatura francesa que a sus 25 años es
el último eslabón de este sistema
su tarea es entregar la ayuda
humanitarias es lo mínimo que yo pueda
hacer para mi ciudad no podemos
quedarnos en casa y esperar esperar eso
me mataría
una persona anciana que lo necesita y
que tiene miedo de salir a la calle
[Música]
otros vecinos están tan asustados que
apenas pueden hablar más ya sólo lleva
también integrante estas redes los
consuelan en jarquín y controla el
territorio gracias a sus contactos en el
ejército
[Música]
tomó más o menos hace un mes cayeron
unos miles y murió un chico de 18 años
de formación
y
dejar que los voluntarios hacen una
labor imprescindible porque la
administración regional se ocupa de la
guerra y hay muchas personas necesitadas
no hay pasa en heart
[Aplausos]
la artillería se sigo yendo todo el día